A former teammate of Babe Ruth’s once recalled
the Bambino by saying, “You’ve got to
remember, this guy wasn’t born.
He fell out of a tree.”
Ruth grabbed life by the throat (or maybe
it was another part of life’s anatomy) and
shook it up… frequently.
Ruth spent a good portion of his youth cooped
up in St. Mary’s industrial school, listed
as an “incorrigible”.
After he was released, Ruth seemed to spend
the rest of his life “making up for lost
time.”
He went through women like they were Lay’s
Potato Chips
Most men, even the greatest ladies’ men,
have particular “favorite types” of women,
subjective turn-ons, and particular traits
they especially like in the opposite sex.
Ruth seemed unusual in his complete lack of
this quality.
Ruth just simply loved women- tall women,
short ones, fat ones, thin ones, beautiful
knockouts, ugly rejects, socialites, film
starlets, secretaries, other men’s wives,
and hookers.
If the individual was a woman, he was interested.
According to his teammates, it was an extremely
rare day that passed during his baseball career
(1914-1935) that he did not find some lady
to become “friendly” with.
He liked women as much as baseball.
And during his career, women constantly threw
themselves at him.
This worked out for his teammates too, as
there were more than even he could handle,
and most were happy to go with the backup
options.
(You have to remember, even early in his career
when he wasn’t “The Great Bambino”,
he wasn’t the tubby ballplayer most of us
remember today.
He was quite the physical specimen early on
and very tall for his era.)
Ruth was crazy about prostitutes and loved
frequenting brothels.
Prostitutes, unlike most women who threw themselves
at him, wanted nothing but money and were
much less complicated for the star.
Often during his career, St. Louis fans would
be “touched” by the Babe as he would say
he frequented “The House of the Good Shepherd.”
Most assumed, given he was Catholic, he was
going to church.
Little did they know, “The House of the
Good Shepherd” was a brothel in St. Louis.
According to one of Ruth’s roommates early
in his career, Ping Bodie, two nights in a
row Ruth managed to go through “all the
girls” at one Philadelphia brothel…
Most such brothels at that time had around
a dozen women on staff at any given time.
There are numerous similar stories from other
teammates that paint the same picture of Ruth’s
libido, which even if exaggerated a bit, seem
to make it a miracle he had energy left to
play baseball.
Of course, anyone who lives this type of a
lifestyle is bound to upset a few people,
especially in the era he lived in.
All this carnal activity had it’s inevitable
casualties.
Once, sports writers were chatting on a train
in 1921 when they were amused to see the Babe
running like mad through the club car, with
a furious woman chasing him brandishing a
knife.
It was later discovered that the woman, who
was married, had thought she was the “only
one” and that he was in-love with her.
When she found out the truth, out came the
knife.
In a similar story, but with an angry husband
in Detroit this time, reporters were treated
to the sight of a nearly naked Ruth chased
out of a hotel room he’d been sharing with
the man’s wife.
The man brought a gun, but lucky for Ruth,
chose not to shoot him, but simply give him
a scare.
In a case that, for a time, looked extremely
bleak for the Bambino, late in 1922, Ruth
was slapped with a “breach-of-promise”
suit for $50,000 (about $677,000 today), filed
on behalf of Dolores Dixon, a teenage employee
at a Manhattan department store.
She claimed she had become pregnant by Ruth.
She said he had raped her and later promised
to marry her.
She also claimed they’d met numerous times
for liaisons in his car.
The matter went to trial in 1923.
Ruth claimed he’d never seen the girl in
his life.
Given the number of women he’d slept with,
perhaps this wasn’t a strong indicator that
he’d actually not done what the girl said.
While she was a teen (19) and technically
underage in the area she lived (21 was the
age of consent at the time there), few of
that era cared about her age.
What the public wanted to know was whether
he’d actually sexually assaulted her and
whether the child was his.
Long story short, nope and nope.
In fact, there was no Dolores Dixon.
It was a made up name.
“Dixon’s” lawyer later admitted they’d
hoped the Babe would settle out of court to
keep the story out of the public eye.
Ruth called their bluff and took them to court,
at which point it became apparent the girl
and her lawyer’s story was all made up and
that she was simply desperate for money and
was inspired by Ruth’s reputation as a playboy
to make up a story and extort some money from
him.
Given his tendencies, she might have pulled
it off had she simply written to him and hooked
up with him a few times as she said in her
story.
While he hadn’t committed the despicable
acts “Dixon” accused him of, his behavior
was deplorable for another reason- during
his peak womanizing years, he had a wife whom
he sorely neglected.
Ruth went through life like a cyclone, but
of all the people he touched, possibly none
was hurt as much as his first wife.
Helen Woodford was an auburn-haired Texas
girl, sweet and quite pretty.
She was a waitress in a Boston cafe where
Ruth met and fell in love with her, or perhaps
just in-lust.
By all accounts, she was extremely shy and
a very innocent girl, perhaps appealing to
him because, unlike so many other women, she
wasn’t throwing herself at him.
Whatever the case, they were married in a
Catholic church in 1914; Ruth was 2o and she
was 17.
Throughout their 14 years of marriage, poor
Helen’s life with Ruth was pure hell.
He gave her furs, an 80-acre farm and an adopted
daughter named Dorothy (who was Ruth’s child
through one of his affairs, this one to Juanita
Jennings, though Helen reportedly did not
know the child was really his); he gave her
neither time, love, nor fidelity.
His countless affairs with other women caused
her to have a nervous breakdown.
She finally left Ruth in 1928 and the following
year- while living with a dentist in Watertown,
Mass- she died in a mysterious house fire.
At the time, they were still married as, being
Catholic, they couldn’t get divorced.
Affairs, at least as far as Ruth was concerned,
apparently didn’t conflict with his religion.
Divorce, though… oh the scandal.
Ruth mourned her briefly.
Three months later, Ruth married ex-chorus
girl Claire Merritt Hodgson.
She was classy, well-off, extremely strong-minded
and a great beauty who had a liking for ballplayers.
(Ty Cobb stated that he dated Hodgson before
Ruth and that things had gotten serious for
a time.)
She was one of the women Ruth were having
an affair with when Helen was alive.
He married Claire in 1929 and she did the
impossible, taming him and managing to change
his entire lifestyle.
She put him on a strict diet and curbed his
drinking.
She saved his money and forced a ten o’clock
curfew on him when he went to parties.
Most remarkable of all, he mostly did what
she said.
Claire knew all about the Babe’s other women
and this reckless habit too was finally, mostly,
curbed.
For a time, she even traveled with him while
he was on the road to make sure he stuck to
her rules.
After a while, she got tired of all the travel,
though, and decided Ruth occasionally doing
things he shouldn’t was a fair trade for
getting to spend more time with her family
and friends back home.
While he didn’t go back to the extreme playboy
ways he’d exhibited before, while on the
road at this point, he had the occasional
affair.
At home, he was generally a dutiful husband.
Apparently the situation worked for them.
Claire was very possibly the one and only
woman Ruth ever met who he actually respected
and, to the end, their 19-year marriage was
by all accounts a relatively happy one.
Babe Ruth died on August 16, 1948.
Millions of baseball fans mourned his death-
and so did countless women who cared nothing
about baseball whatsoever.
Although, from accounts of more than a few
broken hearts he left along the way, there
were probably a few who secretly rejoiced.